[Music]
meanwhile can we do a little throwback
Thursday to a movie I know we all love
the Karate Kid ever wonder what happened
to Danielson aka Ralph Macchio well
nearly 35 years later we are finding out
on the new YouTube red series Cobra Kai
holy art Brooke Anderson was invited to
the Atlantis a Daniel ruse has become
very successful
he's the auto king of the San Fernando
Valley he's happily married with two
great kids not everything is says seen
Ralph who's now 56 isn't the only
original cast member making a comeback
in Cobra Kai this is Johnny Lawrence he
and I go way back oh this guy was a
sheik eight you want to get technical I
kicked his face yes the rivalry is is
reborn at at a higher level this little
old grudge match hasn't gone away he's
moved on into his world and I've degress
it into my world
I heard you beat up a bunch of teenagers
I didn't beat up any teenagers the 10
episode series is being produced by Will
Smith's production company
there will be references to mr. Miyagi
Pat Morita who passed away in 2005 and
yes both Ralph and Billy still have some
of those karate moves
I have a little surprise for you we were
on set with you all those years ago we
had one minor injury I just took a
little one here nothing nothing major
that's the worst of it we're we're in
good shape
I mean I remember that I remember the
kick to it I still feel it we did all
that stuff flat out ourselves and
especially being the 90-pound weakling I
mean I was definitely set up for some
injury what's your real life family
think about you doing this they're very
like my kids that are in their 20s I
know people like what
but yeah many people feel like that's
what I do that's what I do
[Music]